これわざとじゃないんです
深い理由があってこんなことになっています僕は物を買うとき穴頭をよく使うんです
けれども
中津の構図でパンツのこのぴぴパッこれを使おうと思ってチャージもうさとプレゼン
こんなには600なかったんですよ
何だろう days
あのこれはこれ一つで一個じゃなくて単位が
12袋でこんなんです頭に袋で行っという中で頭いかれちゃいますよね
12袋っていうことを知らなくて列を知ってたのかな
12袋でこれはご注文捨てた60袋買おうと思ってたんですよ
どこっ他のところの
ゼロが一つ多くて
50個
注文してしまいました
アマゾンさんから変なメールが来てなんか数量が多すぎてい
なんかば穴のサイズつになりますが送料に問題はありません
ありがとうございますみたいなやつって
何かおかしいなと思ったんですけどもよく見返してみると
何パン成600個買っていますなんで
0多かったがマネージャーさんにも相談してそのちょっとマジでやばいするというの
ずっと俺ん家にそのまま the
コンソメパンチが600億円でちょっとお姉さんやばいですマジコン生600きますみ
た
監査名600点だっ
僕まで困ったんですよダンボールばカフェの
たくさん来てもうヤバかったんですよサイバーテロだと思って
ユーチューバーがディスってるアンチとかがサイバーテロね俺の構造パンチ買う時に
01個増やして送って50かける12で600の講座が続てよみたいな
わかりますか
笑い事じゃないんですけど愛知個人としてとても困っててそのマネージャーさんにも
なんか返品できますってきたんですけど俺は返品しないことを選びましたたのだだ俺だ
し
サイバーテロでもない
妻はてるのはないから
俺の店だと思ってこれはかなあー
混在パンツをすべている
受け止めますでも
せっかくだし
presents 曲にしましょう
これしかないでしょずっとこれ号前じゃない感じだから大事なこの交差でパンチ
600服あるんですけども登録者が100万に行った時も
プレゼント期間てから結局セグ映画プレゼントできなかったって今回なんとこうそう
いうパンツ big bag を500フクロウ
プレイずをします
100袋俺のもんだ
いやまずやのネタじゃないからこんなのバンドとしないからね高生パンツ600袋買っ
ては何も起きないからねマジでわざとじゃないのうち取り返して5名の方に
金さんパンチビックバックを100袋プレゼントしますオーガせる条件が2つあります
ひとつはこの
このチャンネルですはじめ社長のこのチャンネルをチャンネル登録をしていることを
それとはその道路の説明欄のえっと応募フォームにちゃんと応募することをこの2つが
条件ですこの2つが高層パンツ100円の地小路部今日から1週間後ですね
ウンジェ6年この日のこの時間までに押してください
なんかもう自分の文を見るだけで笑っちゃって切っちょっと僕の店でとんでもないこと
になったんですけれども
なんと猫プレゼント客んで中ということでやれば良かったのかなと思っています
良くはないですよ中万円細いパンチ20万円近く守ってくれてるんで僕はサイバーテロ
買ってまで疑っています町名は
だけで裁判たので本当にパンチは600分に届いたという動画でした
じゃあ
144初級授業もようですねんセフレ
はっ半分も期待しちゃうそれでこれでしょ
ちょっと3倍ぐらいるって言葉だまず全然来てないんだけどねまじか600だか言っ
ちゃったら
だから amazon からメール来たんだ
理由てって中 amazon かなぁ
その高すぎるんでまぁこは決して費を別にして負けますみたいなんですねうんうんそれ
はということが入っちゃったよ
600部船艇雪で今600なくてこれがあと34回きます
サイバーテロぞ細いまた釣っえっマジで言ってるのか